Adam thank you so much for joining us
it's great to have you here thanks for
having me
so aside from being here and doing this
interview how is your job different now
that you're CEO oh well we made a couple
of changes over the last quarter and one
of the things that I've done is
inherited some numerous possibilities
we brought the revenue product team
closer to my team and also the media
team but in general look I'm having the
time of my life that the product and the
business are going really well now we
have to start with user growth because
by one metric you lost 2 million core
users then jack says well it's actually
ticking back up what's actually
happening right now with user growth
yeah so what's actually happening right
now is that our user growth in January
has bounced back to our original levels
and we're confident actually in the
product work that we have ahead and that
product work will drive user growth to
you know a sustained period of growth
for the long term if we if we execute
the product changes that we put in place
already in fact we made one yesterday
where you can turn on a simple switch
and get the best of Twitter in your
timeline we think things like that while
small we'll continue to refine what's an
iconic product you say a sustained
period of growth how confident are you
give us a confidence check how confident
are you that you can re accelerate user
growth oh we're confident in the product
roadmap and we're confident in the
trends that we're actually seeing and
some of the trends actually are already
good signs that we talked about in in
earrings call yesterday are da you for
example in terms of as a percentage of
da you daily active users - monthly
active users actually went up for this
past quarter so the signs are there for
sure
but make no make no mistake product
execution ultimately will drive user
growth we feel like we've got a great
product roadmap and we're confident in
the road ahead how confident are you in
Jack Dorsey who has another full-time
job yes so you know jack talked about
his ability to manage both jobs on the
earnings call yesterday I can only speak
from my point of view I've seen him in
action and from a product standpoint
he's unbelievable with the tea
he's got a vision for the company and
you know I'm fascinated by him and his
ability to execute at the company and
he's doing a great job now you live and
breathe Twitter you built the revenue
engine for this company how do you deal
with the the sort of incessant
negativity that surrounds the company
and how is it impacting morale I mean we
know a lot of people have left we know
more people are looking yeah look I
think the morale of the company there's
a massive set of determination at the
company to prove the outside world wrong
and look we heard this on the business
side two five and a half years ago when
we started the business the question was
hey how are they going to monetize the
business if you look at 2015 we had a
really strong 2015 in terms of revenue
growth close to 60 percent year-on-year
growth for 2015 in q4 for this past
quarter what we just announced was
revenue that was over 50% on a constant
currency-based basis so there were
questions about our ability to monetize
we've proven them wrong over the last
five and a half years and I look at the
next five and a half years is a great
chance to prove them wrong again on that
note though revenue growth is slowing
down and guidance suggests upward into
40 percent it was forty eight percent
last quarter revenue growth seems to be
slowing dramatically what's going to
turn that around let me talk a little
bit about what's happening in the
business you know in our revenue stream
on the advertising side we have two
categories of advertisers there's big
branded advertisers so these are people
for example that run TV commercials and
the like and then we have smaller
performance advertisers these people
looking for clicks and conversions and
mostly with inside of digital spend the
brand advertisers business is the
largest percentage of our business and
the growth there since we've covered
most of those advertisers the growth
there is gonna come from just growth and
budgets although we're growing nicely we
just launched video advertising for
example on Twitter and that's growing
budgets the performance business is a
small is a smaller set of our advertiser
revenue but it is extremely fast-growing
and ultimately we have a product driven
approach ahead to drive that revenue
schedule that's the business that people
are concerned about direct response
advertising
why are you having trouble with well
it's not that we're having trouble we
started with the branded advertising
business first and this was the this was
the thing when we looked at five and a
half years ago in terms of the business
and the big brand advertisers were
already on the platform and so we didn't
have to Pied Piper them to the platform
we knew that if we could just make it
easier for them to expand business on
Twitter it would be successful we saw it
this past weekend during the Superbowl
during the Superbowl 90% of the
television advertisers were also running
ads on Twitter and over fifty percent of
that budget was actually running with
instead of our video platform as well
why don't you create a model where the
best content creators can share revenue
from Promoted Tweets I mean if if this
is a social platform for creative
creators and users why not make it a
money-making opportunity for them it
worked for Google it's a great idea and
it's actually something we've already
started so Jack talked a little bit
about one of the key priorities for us
was around creators and helping drive
creation on the platform on the video
side we've got two initiatives one is
our amplify program and this is a
program for a premium content providers
to bring content on the platform and
share in revenue we now have over 225
television networks and premium content
providers doing this in 25 countries all
across the world we've begun to expand
this out to move beyond just premium
content providers to allow other
creators to upload video and share in
the revenue that we sell and then the
second thing we're doing is we have a
platform called niche which now has over
25,000 content provider or content
creators who use the platform and
essentially what it does is it helps
bring together advertisers with content
creators so content creators can provide
great content for those advertising
campaigns so we hear the rumors
constantly about twitter selling have
you considered selling have you gotten
offers the board has a fiduciary duty to
shareholders and I think you know from
the management teams perspective our
goal is to increase shareholder value
and we believe the roadmap that we have
ahead and the team that we have in place
is a strong team and we're continuing to
see growth LinkedIn is worth 50% of what
it was a week ago you're trying to turn
around a company
in an unforgiving market I mean is there
any part of you that thinks maybe this
would be easier or better if we were
private or if we were under someone
else's way look we don't even think
about that piece of it here's what we do
think about Twitter is a live platform
live is amazingly powerful for people
it's also amazingly powerful for the
business and it's our core strength you
see on the video side for example
products like periscope which we've now
integrated into Twitter are incredibly
compelling for both areas consumers and
the business side so I feel like we have
all of the right pieces in place the
business is growing and ultimately
consumer growth will be there as well
why not innovate faster or bigger like
why not just do do away with 140
character limit right now and see what
happens so we have started refining the
product in fact yesterday we turned on a
feature I encourage you and the people
at home I've seen it turn it on it's an
extension of our while you're away
feature which is if you haven't been to
Twitter for a while we bring the very
best tweets right to the top of your
timeline you simply pull your timeline
again and you go right back to live and
what's great about it is you know we
have over 300 million pieces of our
content creators on the platform who are
giving incredible insight and
information you think about you know
just what's happened over the last two
weeks for example in the political realm
politicians when they want to speak
directly to the world they do it on
Twitter first for the Super Bowl we had
players and journalists who were
communicating about the game and
actually a player who was at home who
decided to retire Marshawn Lynch just
through a tweet so I think you see
examples like that and you can't help
but think and know that Twitter is a
platform that is going to continue to to
really dominate Jack says his number one
priority is recruiting especially in the
executive ranks where are the holes what
are the gaps that you think need to be
filled well a baby or CLO yeah a big one
actually was on the marketing side
communicating the value of the company
to consumers in a stronger way was
definitely one of the priorities
Jack and I had over the summer as we
laid out the strategy for the company
I'm happy to say we've done that Leslie
Berlin who's an incredible executive
from American Express has just joined us
and actually started this week as our
chief marketing officer and she's going
to get right in right right to work to
help do that both on our performance ad
business and also for TV as well one
more question you're gonna like this one
you're known for being so nice in fact
recode actually turned that into a
headline but recently I've been seeing a
little bit more attitude
from Adam Bain when Wendy's and Burger
King had a smackdown on Twitter Facebook
said it happened on quote/unquote social
media and you weren't too happy with
that according to your tweets I love
Twitter and I want to make sure that
people understand the true power and
impact that it has in the world and it
is powerful are we gonna see being like
a little last night I can be a little
bit less nice all right Adam Bain CEO of
Twitter thank you so much for joining
thanks for having me